- Hello, it's Chocolate Week!
Ooh, I love chocolate.
Are you a chocolate man, Noel?
- No, I'm an actual man.
- BOTH: - Welcome to
The Great British Bake Off.
- Last time...
It was Bread Week.
- Oh, crumbs.
- While Marc proved a worthy
Star Baker...
APPLAUSE
..it was Rowan who unravelled...
- It looks just like a bit
of a shambles.
- You've gone for all style
and no substance.
- ..and became the latest baker to
leave the tent.
- I'm glad. I didn't really want
to do Chocolate Week!
- HE CHUCKLES
- But for the remaining Bakers...
- Don't drop, don't drop, don't drop!
- ..Chocolate Week has arrived...
- Literally melting in my hands.
- ..with a back-to-basics
signature...
- Brownies are one of the most
basic things to bake.
If you can't get that right...
- You're getting hammered! - Ruthless.
- A return to bread in the
technical...
- What have we got to prove?
Everything.
- Maybe if you stroke it,
it'll get a bit bigger. - Might do!
- ..and the Show Stopper...
- At the moment,
they're saying it's 25 degrees.
Not ideal for white chocolate.
- ..that gets them
all hot under the collar.
- Don't forget -
you only have to be not the worst.
- LAUGHTER
What a great mantra that is!
"Just don't be the worst."
- Chocolate Week!
- SHE LAUGHS
- Yeah, it's fun.
Absolute fun, this one.
- Massive chocoholic!
A day without chocolate
is a day wasted, in my opinion.
- Chocolate releases endorphins,
but that tent does not always
release endorphins!
I think it is quite a stressful
place, so um...
Maybe if I have some chocolate
halfway through my bake,
I'll feel a bit better!
- Hello, Bakers.
Welcome to the tent.
It is Chocolate Week and it's time
for your signature challenge. OK...
- HE WHISPERS: - Their names are Paul
and Prue.
- Yeah, I know. - You say that, but you
always get them wrong. - No, I don't!
- All right. Paul and Prue. - I know!
Praul and Pue would like you
each to make a batch of
18 chocolate brownies. You may use
any type of chocolate you like.
- You can use as many additional
flavours as you like,
but we will be looking for that
nice fudgy texture.
And when I say we, I mean...
- Plaul and Plue.
You have one hour and 30 minutes.
- On your marks... - Get set...
- Bake!
Brownies may be famously
simple to make...
- Put anything in a brownie that you
like. As long as you don't
overcook it and keep the middle of
nice and gooey.
- But the Bakers have just 90 minutes
to produce the perfect batch.
- It's the timing that I'm really
worried about.
We're all up against it.
- To get them cooked, cooled and ready
in an hour and a half
is going to be tough.
- The perfect chocolate brownie
has a gooey centre
and it has a crackly crisp top.
And that's it!
- The bake on the brownie is
the most critical thing.
If you over-bake it, it will become
very, very dry and cake-like.
- Although the Bakers can, of course,
decorate their brownies,
all icings are very sweet and extra
chocolate is more sweetness,
so I think they should try not to
over-decorate the top.
- This, for me, is going
back to basics.
If you can't produce a decent
chocolate brownie...
..there's going to be problems.
Hello, Linda. - Good morning!
- Linda, tell us about your brownies.
- These are my Christmas brownies,
they remind me of when I was a kid
and we used to have all the
nuts and Turkish delights
and dates that were a real treat.
- NOEL: - Linda's treats of Christmas
past will be studded into a layer
of white chocolate on top
of her date-filled brownie.
- What texture are we looking for when
we cut into it? - Nice and gooey.
- Gooey? - Nice and gooey. - Good luck,
thank you. - Thank you very much.
- Good luck. - Thank you. - I might just
stay here... - OK.
- ..and wait till they're ready and
then eat them. - Keep stirring that...
If you are going to... - Do you want
me to? - ..be useful. - Oh, OK.
-LINDA LAUGHS
- So, I'm making a rich chocolate
brownie with roasted macadamia.
Surprisingly, I hadn't made brownies
until a few years ago.
I wouldn't say
they're my favourite cake.
- MATT: - Perfecting the recipe for his
praline buttercream brownies,
has given Marc sleepless nights.
- I'm tired! Really tired this
morning. - Are you? I'm quite tired.
I woke up in the middle of the
night, I was sleep-walking and
driving around...
- As a vampire, though, that's what
you're meant to do, isn't it? Get up
at night... - I call it sl
- eepwalking.
- You call it... - ..other people call
it... - Being a vampire!
- Taking people into the bushes
and sucking all their blood out.
I mean, people like to split hairs.
- MATT: - The Bakers' quest for the
perfect gooey centre starts
with their brownie mix.
- I think it's all about the
ratios in your recipe.
So, how much fat you've got,
how much flour you've got.
- If you add too much flour, you're
going to start getting a cake.
- NOEL: - So, getting their calculations
right...
- Little bit too much sugar.
- ..is crucial.
- I like your purple calculator!
- It's good, isn't it?
- I haven't seen calculators for a
while because I have a calculator
app on my phone.
- Yeah, unfortunately, we are not
allowed are phones in here.
- Are you not? - No. - Why? Because
you'd be ringing going,
"Mum, can you come and get me?
I don't like it here.
"They make me bake all day
and then, I bake all day,
"a horrible man with a beard
comes along and says it isn't good."
- NOEL: - But this bake should be
child's play for Dave,
as it is inspired by his favourite
childhood sweets,
which will sit on top of his rich
ganache-topped brownies.
- They'd better take my last cos they
won't be able to eat any more after
they've had min
- e.
NOEL: - Hoping for a slightly
healthier brownie...
- These are some good looking figs.
- ..is Peter.
- Peter, that looks amazing.
- So, I am making fig
and pistachio upside-down brownies.
So, I've got a layer of figs
underneath and that's going to
be flipped out and become the top
and I've got some cinnamon
going into the brownie batter.
It just tastes really good
alongside the chocolate.
- It's very untraditional...
- It's certainly unusual. - It's risky.
MATT: - Peter's hoping for a riot of
texture and flavour with his unusual
fig-topped brown
- ies.
- What did Paul say when you said
"figs"? Did he go...
- SQUEAKILY: - .. "Oo-o-o-oh!"?
Or did he just stare through you
with his cold blue eyes?
- When I said most things,
he just did that, yeah.
- You must have made brownies, right?
Everyone's made brownies.
- Everyone's made brownies, surely.
Have you made brownies?
-I've made brownies...
I haven't made brownies.
No, I have... never baked.
- You've never baked?
Like... ever? Never ever? - Never.
Baking's for losers!
- THEY LAUGH
- This is good inside knowledge.
- I make brownies of the time at home.
My husband does really like
brownies.
But, you know, it's Paul Hollywood
and Prue Leith judging it
and not my husband.
He will eat anything!
- MATT: - Her husband might not be
fussy, but Sura is hoping
to win over the judges today with
her ruby and dark chocolate marble
brownies.
- It could be great...
Or it could be...
We'll see what kind of disaster
this turns out to be.
- Right, so, I'm going in.
170 for 20 minutes.
- NOEL: - Getting their brownies baked
and cooled as quickly as possible is
crucial, if the Bakers are to
leave themselves enough time to cut
and decorate...
- That goes in at 180 for
about 25 minutes.
- ..but Lottie's going to have to
run the oven gauntlet twice.
- They're going to go for 25
minutes to start with and then,
another 25 minutes once
they've got the toppings on.
- MATT: - Lottie's ambitious
double-baked brownies will have
a chocolate and pecan base and baked
raspberry cheesecake topping.
- I have given myself a hellish pile
of work to do. I think I can
get it done. Obviously, what will
suffer is my decoration,
but that's always the case with me.
As long as it tastes all right,
I'm happy.
- Hermine, good morning. - Morning!
- Hermine, tell us
about your brownies.
- So, I'm making raspberry, white
chocolate and pistachio... - Wow.
- ..brownie. - How long are you going to
cook them for?
- Ten minutes on one side, get it out,
and then ten
minutes on the other side.
- How do you mean,
"ten minutes on the other side"?
- Turn around. - Of the tray?
- Yeah, it's a tray.
- The only problem is, when you do
that, you drop the temperature
of the oven.
- Well, isn't that a good
thing for a brownie? - Is it?
NOEL: - Hermine is also adding coffee
to elevate the chocolate flavour
of her brownie, which she's hoping
she can bake to perfection.
- If the baker says, "You're not
supposed to turn it around",
maybe I'm not supposed to
turn it around.
So, we're not going to turn
it around!
- Bakers, you are halfway through!
- That was nice.
- 45 minutes...
- Now I'm going to
make my Italian meringue.
- MATT: - The Bakers' choice of
toppings...
- Going to blitz the hazelnuts...
- ..should enhance
the flavour of their brownies...
- On the top of the brownies is going
to be tiny little cubed
Turkish delight and chopped nuts.
- ..without adding too much sweetness.
- On top of my brownies is going to be
a milk chocolate ganache
with honeycomb.
Yeah, they are a bit sweet.
- This is my cheesecake layer.
This goes back in the oven for
25 minutes or as long as I can
spare, really.
- So, I am making the Italian
meringue buttercream...
- There's a few Italian meringues
I know in the tent today.
- It's like a sweet overload,
but so worth it.
- It's like Donald Trump's hair,
isn't it?
That's how you know
your meringue is done.
You've got a Trump on your whisk!
- Mark's Italian meringue-topped
brownies will sit on a cookie base
in his take on his
favourite camping treat.
- A smore is usually something you
have with marshmallows
and biscuits, sort of,
over by a campfire,
so I thought I'd convert
that into a brownie.
- MATT: - Also hoping to score brownie
points with her smores-inspired bake
is Laura. - Smores is quite an
American term,
but it basically means
melted marshmallow, I think.
But I'm doing a posh version with
Italian meringue.
- NOEL: - Laura's Italian meringue will
be piped on top of her decadent
chocolate and hazelnut brownies,
before being drizzled with a
rich salted caramel sauce.
- The brownies are so,
so sweet that I'm hoping the salt
and the caramel will just... cut
through that
and then, you get that really
nice balance.
- So, these are going
back in for another 25 minutes.
- MATT: - With Lottie just halfway
through her bake time...
- I'm praying to the brownie gods.
- Er... - ..the others...
- Brownie, cook! Brownie, cook!
- ..now face a game of nerves...
- It's never failed me
to leave them in for 33 minutes.
It still stays all nice and fudgy.
- ..as they must judge when their
brownies are perfectly underbaked.
- Ooh, yeah,
they still need a bit longer.
Oh, come on!
- NOEL: Get them out too soon
and they could fall apart.
- That's good, we've got a nice
crack... on top.
- Leave them in too long...
- Just going to give them a couple of
minutes, that's all. Just a couple.
- ..and they risk losing
the fudgy centre.
- Oh, they're still a bit...
Oh, gosh...
Got to give it another five minutes,
that's not good!
- They're completely raw.
- Got to get these in the freezer,
ASAP.
I just need it to cool quickly.
- I think I'm going to take mine
out now.
- I'm going to get it out, I think.
Cos I really don't want
to overdo it.
I do really want a nice,
fudgy middle.
- That looks good to me!
Let's just hope they cool in time.
- Into the fridge -
we've not got long.
- They're still a little bit
raw in the middle.
The thicker they are,
the longer they take to cook, so...
My fault, really.
- Gr-r-r!
- Yours in the oven?
- Yeah, mate, I've got another 15
minutes before they can come out.
It's not going to be pretty,
the end of this.
- Bakers, you have... insert number
of minutes here... minutes remaining.
- SHE GIGGLES
You've actually got half
an hour left.
- That's not enough time.
- What are you doing?
- I'm still baking. - Still in the oven?
- Yeah. - What? - Mm-hm...
- If you need any more time,
I do do the time calls,
so I could cheat for us.
SURA GIGGLES
OK? You know you're my favourite.
Don't tell the others.
- I'm just going to take them out.
- Bakers,
you have 15 minutes remaining.
- Yeah,
what you going to do about it?!
Probably carry on baking
and try your hardest.
- That's very hot. I'm going
to defrost the freezer!
- Don't drop, don't drop, don't drop!
- Ideally, it'd be nice to leave them
a little bit longer before I cut
them, but time's of the essence now.
- When I've not this is practice
and it hasn't gone right,
it's just went... - HE WHISTLES
- ..splurge out the side.
- MATT: Only now will the Bakers find
out if they've judged
their bake times correctly.
- Oh, thank God for that.
- HE GIGGLES GLEEFULLY
- That is perfect inside.
Very happy with that bake.
- A bit raw.
Unfortunately, Paul's going to say,
probably, now that
they're not quite right.
- Let's see how raw it is, shall we?
On a scale of one to raw...
- Do you think it's still raw?
- Oh, yeah,
I'm fairly confident it's raw, yeah.
- Have you got time to put
it in the freezer?
- I did put it in the freezer... - Oh.
- ..and then the freezer melted on it
because it was so hot and then,
now, this is all just wet freezer
juice that... dripped onto it.
- "Wet freezer juice"?!
- Yeah. - So, what have you...?
"What's your topping again, Lottie?
"It's wet freezer juice
"and then, also, I dipped it in bin
juice because I wasn't..."
- Yeah, just for good measure.
- "..wasn't pleased."
So, tuck in, Blue Eyes,
see how that grabs you!
- NOEL CHUCKLES
THUD
SHE SIGHS
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
HE CHUFFS
- You can do this, Bakers.
- Oh, the stress.
Oh, the stress is too much.
- Just piping on the Italian meringue.
- I think these are looking darn,
rootin'-tootin' good!
- Mine are a mess.
- Just going to pop
some of this over there...
They look a treat.
- Yummy, yummy, yummy.
- So, I'm just thinking if I can split
one tin into 18 brownies...
- Oh, what a hot mess.
- UNDER HER BREATH: - No, I'm not going
to try.
- I'm happy with that!
God, to the wire...
- Bakers, your time is up.
Please put your bakes
at the end of your bench.
- Oh, that was horrific. Mine are raw.
They're not cooked. Look at them.
- HE SIGHS
- Well, at least they're gooey!
- Looks like an actual car crash.
- MATT: - The nine batches
of chocolate brownies
now face the scrutiny
of Paul and Prue.
- Hello, Peter. - Hi, Peter.
They look quite attractive
on the top.
- They really look lovely.
It's got the chewiness, but it's
coming from the dates, isn't it?
- Mm. - What spices
did you put in there?
- There's cinnamon in there.
- Mm. - I think there's
too much cinnamon.
Because, actually, the cinnamon
is overtaking the chocolate.
It's different, it's risky.
It's OK.
- NOEL: - That is brutal.
- Thank you. - OK, thank you.
- It's OK. - It's a bit disappointing.
- LAURA: - Oh, dear God, here we go.
- Good luck, honey.
You'll be great.
- Mm. It looks as if they came
out of the oven too early.
- Yeah, it does look a mess.
Let's have a look, shall we?
- I really think
that's too much Italian meringue.
- OK.
- It's too sweet.
- Really? - Far too sweet. - OK.
- Cos you've got caramel,
you've got the meringue on the top,
you've got the chocolate,
you're going, "Mm, enough now."
- It's under baked. - Mm. - So,
you've got a few problems here.
We need to get them out
of there, don't we? - Yeah.
Initially I had
two trays of brownies,
and one of them actually
fell inside the oven.
So, I've just presented one.
- Very tough. - Mm.
- I don't like the flavours either.
- I do! What is it?
- Dark chocolate and ruby chocolate.
- Because I'm getting
a sort of citrusy kick,
but I think that must be
the ruby chocolate. - Yeah.
- Mm. - But...
..the bake's not right. - Mm-hm.
- And, obviously,
you haven't got enough. - Yeah.
- Not your best work. - No.
- We're getting hammered.
- Ruthless.
- OK, well, they look neat.
- And they look pretty identical.
- So, I've got a cookie base,
with a dark chocolate brownie,
with Italian meringue
and some sugared cranberries.
- It tastes like a brownie.
I'm slightly avoiding the top
because I know
that'll be very sweet.
But, overall, I think
it's a really good job.
- Thank you.
- The biscuit base is too thick.
I like your flavour.
I just think your textures
were wrong.
- OK, thank you.
- They're a little bit messy.
- I like the raspberry acidity.
But the white chocolate
is just too much.
- There's a lot going on in that.
You've got coffee, you've got
chocolate, you've got raspberry,
you've got pistachio...
- You've got a hell of a lot of sugar.
- It's very spongelike
rather than brownie-like. See?
Looks like a chocolate sponge.
I like the flavour, though.
It's unusual, it's nice. It just
came down to the bake itself.
- OK, thank you. - Thank you.
They're all pretty even. - Yeah.
- It's over baked.
It's more like a sponge
than a brownie.
Tastes great!
I like the flavour. - Yeah.
- But it lacks the two things
that I think make a brownie,
that is the gooey middle
and the crackly top.
- Yeah. - You made a good tray bake.
- Thank you.
- They don't look good at all. - No.
Yeah, I was running out
of time, basically,
so it was a rush at the end of it.
So, I apologise for that.
- It's quite dry. - OK.
- If you go right to the middle,
it's nice and squidgy. - OK.
- Actually, I think the flavour's OK.
But it does look a mess.
- It does, I know, I'm ashamed of it.
- That's a problem for me
because... - Yeah.
- ..brownies are one of the
most basic things to bake.
If you can't get that right...
- What are they going to say to me,
if that's what
they're saying to Marc?
- MUFFLED: - I'm going to get roasted.
- Well, they don't look great,
do they? - They look a right mess.
It looks like
they've been dropped. - Yeah.
- NOEL CHUCKLES
- Have you got a straw?
- Not on me. Would you like a spoon?
- Mm.
I love the sharpness
of the raspberries.
But there's too much
cheesecake mixture.
Sort of overpowers it.
- Flavour's OK.
Textures are all wrong. - Yeah.
- The look of it's terrible.
- Yeah. - But besides that, brilliant.
- Nailed it. Yeah. Thanks, guys.
If any of us had just presented
like a standard chocolate brownie,
I think we'd be away,
but none of us have,
we've all tried to make it harder
than it needed to be.
- SHE SIGHS - Oh, God.
- We've all done a botched job
of our brownies.
- That was brutal.
I mean, brownies, what are people
watching this going to think of us?
Like, we're meant to be the best
amateur bakers in the country
and cannot make brownies
to please Paul and Prue?
MATT: - The bakers could practise
their brownies,
but their next challenge, shrouded
in gingham, is a complete mystery.
- Hello, bakers.
Welcome back to the tent. It's time
for your Technical Challenge.
Today, it's been set for you
by Paul.
Paul, any words of advice?
- The brownie challenge
was easy, this isn't.
Concentrate on your textures.
- OK, as ever,
this Technical Challenge
will be judged blind,
so we're going to have to ask
these two to leave the tent and...
..have their eyes temporarily
removed by Belgian robots.
Have they gone? - Not yet.
Can you go, please?
- Prue's lurking about
at the entrance.
- OK, Judge Paul Hollywood
would like you each
to make a chocolate babka,
which is a traditional
Jewish loaf cake.
- Your babka must consist
of an enriched dough
with layers of nuts and chocolate.
And it needs to be rolled, split and
then twisted to create the shape.
- Once baked, it should be brushed
with syrup to finish.
- You have two and half hours.
- On your marks. - Get set.
- Bake.
- Babka, here we come!
- Never heard of one.
If brownies are meant to be simple,
then we've got no chance in this.
None of us have.
- I don't know what it is.
I've never made one.
I wish I knew what it looked like.
- So, Paul, why have you chosen
this babka?
- Basically, it's an enriched dough
with a chocolate filling.
You roll it out into a rectangle,
roll it up as if you were making
a Chelsea bun.
- Mm-hm. - Cut that in half, and
it's a case of a spiral twist.
It's a plait, basically.
But you can't make it too long.
If you make it too long,
it'll never fit in the tin.
- Not easy, rather typical
of Paul Hollywood.
- Shall we have a look inside?
And there it is. You've got
that crisp on the outside
and then that beautiful soft inside,
with this gorgeous chocolate mixture
with the hazelnuts in it.
- It's lovely. It's much lighter
than I thought it would be.
- Mm. - I've had it in New York,
and it's not nearly as nice as this.
- I had it in Birkenhead.
- I'm reading and reading
these instructions today
to make sure I'm not
messing anything up.
- Make the dough.
Nothing else.
- No further instruction.
- Thanks, Paul.
- I haven't made enriched that often.
So just have to wing it, won't I?
- Enriched dough,
it's got butter and milk in it,
and you mix it up with the eggs.
Whereas a general dough,
I mean, it's just flour,
yeast and water.
- That's the sound of enriched dough
slopping about.
- You should be able to stretch it
without the dough splitting.
Then you'll know that it's ready.
- I am happy with the dough.
It's really nice and stretchy.
- Mate, this dough, now, is too wet.
There's no windowpane
coming out of that.
- The dough's really nice,
actually. It's quite sticky.
- Roll out the dough into a rectangle,
measuring 40cm x 30cm.
- 30 would be, like, out there.
- Here we are again, trying to make
rectangles out of circles.
OK, spread the cool
chocolate mixture over the dough,
leaving a 1cm border
around the edges.
- I'm just trying to go for
a nice, even layer... ish.
- You're just doing that in such
a liberal, sort of, free way.
- Do you think?
- You're quite free, aren't you?
How free are you?
How free are any of us?
- No, well, exactly. - What's the
freest thing you've ever done?
- Um... - Have you ever got naked
in a public space?
HE LAUGHS - I haven't, no!
- Do you want to do it now?
Me and you could do it now.
- In the Bake Off tent. - Could make
Bake Off history. - We could!
- We could streak in the tent.
- Scatter the hazelnuts over the top.
Roll the dough into a tight roll.
- Pbbt! Lol...
- It's all about the shaping
of the babka.
I'm trying to remember
what exactly it looks like,
in terms of the twists in it.
- Crucial moment.
- "Cut through the
middle of the dough,
"cutting it into two long pieces.
"Then lift the right half
over the left half.
"Fold by the left half
over the right half,
"repeating the process
to make a two-stranded plait."
- That guy over that guy. - Yup.
And then that one over
there. - And then seal.
- That can't be right.
Ha! That looks ridiculous.
What now?
"Carefully lift into the tin."
Absolute jokers.
- Mine is a bit too long.
- This is not 40 cm.
Going to go like this.
This is all extra, it's too long.
- I'm loving your work.
Oh, yeah!
Come on, high five. - There you go.
- From there...
Let me see, prove until
doubled in size. OK.
- What have you got to prove?
Everything, everything
to Paul Hollywood.
- SHE GASPS
Well, that can't be right.
Why doesn't mine fit?
Maybe it will, like, lift in the
middle or something and take shape.
- Don't really know how long
I need to prove it for.
- Half an hour, let's check it.
- I'm going to just set a timer
for ten minutes.
- All right, let's just
get it in, I think.
- I don't know what you're supposed
to do, but you be good to me.
- Yeah, OK, I let them know.
Bakers, you're halfway through.
- Through. - Yeah, they know now.
- There's a lot of waiting
around on proving things.
Slightly unnerving.
- To rise or not to rise.
- That is the question. - Yes.
- # Carefully lift
the loaf into the tin. #
- Mine wasn't carefully lifted.
- # Prove until it
becomes double in size. #
- Good luck with that.
- # Bake!
# Make the syrup,
brush the babka with the syrup! #
That seems fairly straightforward.
- Well, it's got a little bit bigger.
- It's got a bit bigger, hasn't it?
- Yes. Not as big as I would like it.
- Maybe if you stroke it, it'll
get a bit bigger. - It might do.
Generally works.
- HE CLEARS THROAT
I think mine is ready
to go in the oven.
- I still wouldn't say it's doubled.
I think it's like one and one half.
With the time that's left, it's
going to be possible, shall we say.
I'm hoping.
- Right, so it's not doubled in size.
That's the shape that mine's going
to be, and that's the end of it.
- Off we go.
- Just trying to work out how long
it's going to take to bake it.
- So, I'm just going to do
25 minutes for now.
- Oh, I don't know about that.
Maybe I should tuck the ends under.
- It's all in the bake.
- It's the waiting that's the worst.
Just waiting, waiting and hoping.
- How's it going?
- It's really brown on the ends,
because the ends are the bits that
I left out, when clearly,
I was supposed to tuck those in.
- Can you cut the ends off?
- Well, I was tempted,
I was tempted, but then he'll see.
Do you know what I mean?
He'll see that I then carved it.
- You should say to him,
if he goes on, you know. - Yeah.
- "It's a bit burnt at
the end, like." - Yeah.
- "It's a bit burnt at the end, like,
you know, it's a bit over baked."
- Yeah. - If he does that, should go,
"Well I've never
even seen one before.
"I didn't even know
what one was." - Yeah.
Just like that.
- "Yeah, I didn't even
know what one was." - Yeah.
- "Don't put it on me,
it's on you!" - Yeah.
- I think that's what you should do.
- Yeah. Winner-winner.
- Follow my advice.
- SHE CHUCKLES - I shall.
- Bakers, you have five minutes left!
- Coming out.
- Ready, steady...
..babka!
- We've got ourselves a babka.
- I'm happy with that. It's got a
nice little zigzag design in it.
- Well, I quite like it, actually.
Yes, it doesn't look too bad at all.
- There's no rise on that.
Really not convinced
that that's cooked.
And I put all that messy
chocolate stuff all down the side.
Oh, well.
- Going to spread some syrup.
- A bit of syrup to glaze it.
- Seamless.
- Bakers, your time is up.
- Please bring your chocolate babkas
to the front of the tent
and place them
behind your photographs.
- Mine looks like a Viking longboat.
Oh, my God, embarrassment.
- Paul and Prue are looking
for a beautifully risen babka
with a gorgeous chocolate spiral
all the way through,
crispy on the outside
and soft on the inside.
- Right.
Now, looking at this,
it looks good, it's small,
but you can see the lines
all the way through it.
Let's have a look inside.
- That swirl is good.
Mm.
Even though it hasn't risen
as much, it's very tender. - Mm.
It's got a nice bake on it,
and the combination of the
chocolate to the dough is good.
Moving onto number two,
a few issues.
- Sunk in the middle.
- Yeah, not the best-looking babka
I've seen.
- It's not over baked, though.
- No. The flavour's OK.
It's the way it's twisted,
and the way the chocolate's
been put into it,
that's created that drop
in the middle.
Moving on to this one.
This is a nice one, this.
- This looks like a model babka.
- Colour's good.
Stripes are good, it's a
nice bake all the way around.
It's a good height as well.
- Shine's good.
So all it has to do now
is taste good.
Mm! - Good flavour.
- Excellent. - Now, this one...
..big issues with the plaiting side
of things. It's very, very small.
- Looks a bit heavy, too. - Yeah.
- Yeah. - Feels much, much
tighter, doesn't it?
- A bit heavy, generally. - Mm.
OK, moving on.
- It does look like a babka,
doesn't it?
- It does.
- It is amazing, isn't it,
how much chocolate you
can get into the dough?
- Mm. It's got a very cakey
feel to it. - It's lovely.
- Moving on. Big gaps in this.
- It doesn't look so attractive,
does it?
- No, it doesn't.
It needed more proving.
It's very dense, this.
- Mm.
Yeah, it's odd.
- Moving on. Now,
the size of this isn't bad.
A few holes in there, but, actually,
it's quite a nice sized loaf.
- A bit dry.
- Mm. Now, moving on.
Neat, but again, the plait's
not the entire way through.
There's one on the other side. - Yeah.
- Wow, it's heavy.
It's really under proved.
Tastes good, though.
- Funnily enough,
this has got very few plaits,
and yet, the height is there. - Mm.
And you can see there,
it's fairly open.
It could do with being
a little bit more.
- Tastes delicious.
MATT: - Prue and Paul will now rank
the babkas from worst to best.
- OK, in ninth spot,
we have this one.
A lot of you struggled a little bit
with the shaping into the tin.
It seemed to be really high.
- And then in eighth place,
we have this one.
Dave, didn't get much rise on it.
So it was a little bit heavy.
- Sarah is seventh.
Mark is sixth.
Hermine, fifth.
Peter is fourth.
- In third, we have this one.
Very neat, just could've done
with being a little bit higher.
- Right. Now, number two...
..is this one.
Laura, the only thing wrong with it
was that it sank a little bit
in the middle,
but it is a really nice babka.
- Thank you. - So, in first...
..we have this one.
- Well done.
- Have you made one before? - No.
- Very, very good. I think
you did a good job on that.
The swirl was good, the height,
I couldn't fault it.
Well done.
- I know.
I know, I am so...
- SHE LAUGHS DELIGHTEDLY
- ..I'm so shocked myself!
I just followed my instincts,
and there you go.
- That's the first time I've had
good, obviously, praise
and come second and
it's a confidence boost
that I really needed.
- That was horrific.
And that was two challenges
pretty much failed.
So tomorrow, I have
to pull it out the bag
and hope that
the weather is on our side.
It's going to be hard.
MATT: - Just one challenge remains
before the Star Baker is crowned
and one baker will be asked...
- Oh, God.
- ..to leave the tent.
- Hello, bakers. Welcome back to
the tent.
It's time for your
Showstopper Challenge.
Today, the judges would love you to
make a spectacular
white chocolate celebration cake.
- Now, your cake should be made with a
particular celebration in mind.
For instance, it could be the first
time you went to the toilet
all by yourself.
- For Paul, that was last Thursday.
Well done, Paul.
We're all very proud.
- Well done, Paul.
There's your gold star.
No more nappy.
- You get three of those, you get
a book token, little man.
- Mm. Your cake should have a
minimum of two layers,
and the decoration needs to display
an expert use of white chocolate.
- You have four hours.
- On your marks.
- Get set.
- B. - A. - K. - E.
- White chocolate's a bit of a crowd
pleaser,
so hopefully it's going to be a
good, yummy bake
that the judges like.
- I love white chocolate, which is why
it's so dangerous
having massive jars of these around.
- I'm blitzing it because it does
incorporate a bit better.
Also, though, let's be honest,
I don't know what I'm doing
with this one.
It's a gamble.
- The Showstopper Challenge is to make
a white chocolate tiered cake.
One of the big challenges for the
bakers, actually,
is introducing the white chocolate
into the sponge.
White chocolate has a higher fat
content,
which means, if they've got butter
in the sponge as well,
they need to reduce that so they're
not really upping that fat content
in the sponge, which will disrupt
the texture of the cake itself.
- I think it's a really tricky
challenge.
Because white chocolate is frankly
a nightmare to work with.
It splits at the drop of a hat,
it seizes if you get it too hot,
and I think the bakers will have
their work cut out.
- With the weather being so warm
today,
the bakers are going to have to be
extremely careful
how they introduce the white
tempered chocolate
or ganaches on the outside.
They're going to have to compensate
for the fact that
they may start to melt.
- Hopefully the ambient temperature
in here doesn't go above 20,
otherwise we're all in for a bit of
a worry.
- I'm not a massive fan of white
chocolate,
because, although I have got a sweet
tooth, it's very sweet.
And it's very one-note,
white chocolate.
But I think, in a cake, you can
kind of celebrate it
with other things, which is
hopefully
what I'm going to do today.
- Laura's white chocolate sponges
will be sandwiched
with Italian meringue buttercream
and a sharp blackcurrant jam.
And, for a touch of romance,
she'll be decorating
with a chocolate bouquet
to celebrate her two-year wedding
anniversary.
- It was your wedding anniversary
yesterday? - Yeah.
- How exciting. - Yeah.
- What did you do to celebrate?
- I was here, making brownies.
- You were here in a tent.
- And getting absolutely rinsed by
Paul Hollywood.
- Getting told off by a grumpy man
with a beard.
- Yeah, basically. Yeah.
- That's a great way to spend your
anniversary. - Do you think?
- Romance is also in the air
for Lottie.
- It is a celebration cake for my
grandparents,
because they are celebrating their
Sapphire wedding anniversary
in January. - What is Sapphire?
- 65 years.
- That's incredible. - Yeah.
- Lottie's ambitious design will
feature
a sapphire geode effect
and an array of tempered white
chocolate decorations.
- Have you practice this?
- I have practised this cake between
15 and 18 times.
- Oh, Lottie!
- Yeah, this is a really tricky one
for me.
- Don't forget, you only have to be
not the worst.
- What a great mantra that is.
"Just don't be the worst."
- "Don't be the worst."
- Well, good luck, then.
- Thank you very much.
Oh, well, that spurs you on,
doesn't it?
- Making a tiered cake requires
perfect light sponges.
- If you're trying to stack it,
you need it to be light,
otherwise it will collapse on
itself.
- So it's crucial the bakers gets
the ratio of white chocolate
to butter spot on.
- Because white chocolate has such
a high cocoa butter content,
I've used a little bit less butter
than I would normally.
- Too much white chocolate will
just...
So, essentially, I'm using a small
amount that I will incorporate
very gently in.
- It's very temperamental.
It's like the worst chocolate to
work with.
- Sura, good morning. - Good morning.
- Hello, Sura.
- How are you feeling today? Yesterday
wasn't your best day.
- No, it wasn't. It was horrific.
But today I'm optimistic and hoping
for the best.
- From horrific to optimistic.
- Celebrating her parents' 36th
wedding anniversary,
Sura's elaborately decorated cake
will feature
tempered chocolate truffles and
piped buttercream flowers
that will encase layers of
strawberry and lemon jam
and white chocolate sponges.
- How are you getting the chocolate
into your cake?
- I've watered it down. So it's going
to make it a looser texture,
but, also, it's still going to have
the flavour,
without the heaviness of
white chocolate.
- Good luck, Sura.
- Thank you so much. Thank you.
- Good luck. - Thank you.
While Sura is banking on diluted
white chocolate,
Peter is going for an altogether
different texture.
- I'm just adding chunks of white
chocolate.
I really like it when you come
across that hunk
of white chocolate in a bit of cake,
so that's what I'm going to be doing
in this one.
- Peter's chocolate-studded sponges
will be sandwiched
with a mango curd and whipped cream,
and surrounded with a chocolate
collar
painted with complex equations.
It's the celebration of his brother
Andrew's recent graduation
from a degree in mathematics.
- He graduated this year, but he
hasn't had a full ceremony
because of Covid. - Yeah.
- So I'm celebrating that through
this cake.
- Celebrate it in the tent where
he can't eat it, and we can.
- I've practised one at home, and
he's been able to enjoy it.
- All right, OK.
NOEL: Hermine is building her cake
from Genoese sponges,
where whisked eggs and flour are
traditionally combined
with melted butter.
- I'm replacing the butter with
the white chocolate, here.
That reminds me of the wedding cakes
at my parents' wedding.
Not that I was there, because I was
still really young.
But I've seen pictures of it.
- Her throwback wedding cake will be
decorated
with a white chocolate collar
and piped ganache roses.
Inside, she will layer her delicate
sponges with lemon curd
and Italian meringue buttercream.
- Well, I love Genoese.
I think it's beautiful.
- It's a nice combination of flavours
as well with the lemon.
- Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
- So, if Paul Hollywood is not
complementary,
are you going to take one of the
cakes
and smush it into his face?
Say, "Well, now see how you like
it?"
- Could you do that?
- I'll do it.
- You'll get away with it. I wouldn't.
- You would get away with it.
You'd be a national treasure for
doing that.
- But Mark is hoping to keep all three
tiers of his cake intact.
Dedicated to his daughters,
Rosie and Jasmine,
it will be decorated with their
namesake flowers
and sandwiched with raspberry Swiss
meringue buttercream.
- I'm nervous because the comments
weren't particularly good
yesterday and I know cakes aren't
particularly my strong point.
So, yeah...
In my perspective, I'm feeling
I'm close to the bottom.
- There's also a lot riding on this
bake for Linda.
- This really means a lot to me,
this cake, you know?
It's a tribute to my daughter,
actually.
Melissa had special needs.
She's no longer with us.
You know, she passed away when she
was 18.
But this is just a celebration of
her life, really.
And she was just a sweet little
English rose.
- MATT: - Linda will craft a chocolate
rose to sit atop
an all-white three-tiered sponge
filled with Amaretto, raspberry jam
and mascarpone cream.
- You had a little triumph yesterday.
- I did, didn't I?
I really enjoyed it. - Looked like you
were really enjoying yourself.
- In actual fact, the directions
were really brilliant.
- Yeah, thank you very much.
- Don't give him any credit!
- No, they was really good.
- Have you got one of my books, then?
- I have. - I think you're going
to do really well.
- THEY LAUGH
- OK, here we go.
Attempt number one.
Please. Please bake.
- With their sponges in the ovens...
- I'm going to check it after about
26 minutes, to be precise.
- ..the bakers now turn their
attention to the fillings...
- God, I love multitasking!
- ..which means even more
white chocolate.
- This is going to be white chocolate
overload, but, you know,
that's what they asked for.
- What they do in this show is,
they make tell you to make really
sweet cakes,
and then they tell you off.
Yeah, Prue will just go,
"It's too sweet."
"Actually, it's just a little sweet.
And you go, "Yeah, because you told
us to make a cake
"full of white chocolate!"
"I've always thought, maybe, to
balance out the sweetness,
"you could have put some mud
in there."
- Luckily, Mark's wife, Laura, is a
big fan of this cake,
as it's in honour of her birthday.
Covered in tempered chocolate shards
and geometric shapes,
the interior is full of her
favourite flavours -
white chocolate, pistachio, lemon,
and a South African marula fruit
cream liqueur.
- This is Laura's favourite drink.
And elephants get drunk on this.
Elephants eat fermented marula fruit
and get drunk.
Yeah.
So I quite like it, yeah.
I thought I'd fire it in here, yeah.
- I'm not happy with the cakes.
It just looks really bumpy
and uneven.
It's either start again or hold out.
I think I might need to do them
again.
- Just three hours of the bake remain.
- That goes so quickly. That's one
hour gone.
- Yeah, they're not right.
No, they're really not right.
I'm going to stick to what I know.
Equal quantities of everything.
- Who would you most be upset
if someone went?
Got a few? - I'm not going to say
that.
- You always say that.
- No, I'm not going to say.
Cos we're all really good people
in here.
- This will come out much later,
and by then you won't care.
Paul? Would you like to get rid of
Paul? - Yeah, let's get rid of Paul.
- This batch really does need to
behave,
because otherwise I am definitely
screwed.
- As Laura plays catch up,
it's a critical point in the bake
for the others.
- I know by the colour,
that's not ready.
So I'm going to actually leave it
a little bit longer.
- The high sugar content in white
chocolate means the sponges
will brown very quickly...
- Five minutes.
- ..which could deceive the bakers
into thinking
they're baked through.
- They're a lovely colour.
They need just maybe a minute or
two.
- Oh, I don't know.
- I'm actually going to put them
in for another two minutes.
I listen to my cakes to hear how
bubbly they are.
If they're very, very bubbly
then there's a lot of liquid
left in them.
You don't want a wet cake.
- It is definitely ready.
- Yep, I think they're coming out.
- Really happy with them.
They look great.
Yeah, nice and golden.
- I'm just trying to play catch up,
really.
But I've got my cakes in the oven,
so fingers crossed.
- Hi, David.
- Good morning. - Hello, David.
Tell us about your cake.
- So, today, my cake's going to be
called
a Strawberry Splash White Chocolate
Frasier Cake.
- Oh, Frasier cake. Nice.
You put the strawberries all round
the outside?
- Round the outsides, yeah.
I've got white chocolate creme
mousseline in the middle.
It's going to be decorated with
tempered white chocolate splashes.
- Dave's splashes will sit on top
of his Amaretto-soaked sponges.
This is a cake he loves to bake for
his girlfriend Stacy's birthday,
and no birthday is complete
without balloons.
- What's happening here with these
little guys?
- So, look, there's one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight.
- I can count.
- Yeah, there's one for each baker.
- And what are they going to be?
- They're going to be chocolate
splashes.
- Splashes? - Mm.
- You're doing one for everyone? - Yeah.
- Aw, that's so sweet.
- And...
- And then you're going to burst them
one by one
as you rise through the ranks.
- Bakers, you are through-way half.
Is that right? - Yeah.
- I think everyone's pretty focused
today. There's no chat.
Not as much fun as I thought it was
going to be, I'll be honest.
No chat from Mark. Everyone's
taking it really seriously,
like it's some sort of competition,
or whatever.
- You join us in the middle of a very
important bake.
It's all happening.
Laura is checking the temperature of
her sponges.
Laura, what do we think?
- Right, these two are done.
- Yeah. Talk into the microphone,
please.
- Oh, sorry. These two are done.
- Excellent.
- I think the others just need...
Actually, no, they're not done.
- These two are NOT done.
- False alarm.
False alarm, everybody.
- Newsflash.
Breaking news - they are not done.
- One more minute.
- We will come back to you later.
In the meantime, we'll go to
the weather.
- The thermometer's saying it's
25 degrees.
Not ideal for white chocolate.
- And not ideal conditions for
stacking layers of sponge
with delicate, creamy fillings.
- This is all feeling a little bit
warm at the moment,
so I'm going to have to try and work
as quick as I can.
- I have to go like the clappers.
- The assembly shouldn't
take too long.
It's the chilling part that I need
the most amount of time on,
to really firm up the mousseline.
- As the layers build...
- So hot.
- ..the bakers will need to make full
use of the fridges
to stop them melting and sinking in
the ever-warming intent.
- Really glad I remade them.
They're looking really good.
Much better, yeah.
Panic averted.
Hot.
- Bakers, you have one hour left.
- NOEL WHISTLES
- That's not long.
- If dealing with white chocolate in
their sponges wasn't hard enough,
the bakers also need to temper it to
make their decorative elements.
- I'm just hoping they don't pop.
- Now I'm making my white
chocolate collar.
I'm going to just spread it out on
the acetate
and then put it around the cake.
- This is the messy bit.
- This is just a lacy sort of
collar thing
that I'm putting around the outside
of it.
- It kind of partially sets on the
acetate,
and then it's easier to pick up and
lift onto and around the cake.
- LAURA SIGHS
- It's a mess, isn't it?
- Too hot.
Literally melting in my hands.
Too, too hot.
I'm just going to do some chocolate
drips down the side.
That's all I can do now.
- IN AN AUSTRALIAN ACCENT: Bakers,
you've got ten minutes left.
Don't mess it up.
- It's pretty satisfying.
- Ah, it's not coming off.
I may not get the rows done,
but I'm hoping to.
I'm going to just smooth this off.
- IN AN AUSTRALIAN ACCENT: - Guys,
you have about nine minutes left.
You need to start making your cakes
round about now.
- Do speed up, Lottie.
- I wanted much longer to be
able to do this.
- Looks good, doesn't it?
- It's just not working.
- I'm painting on some maths symbols
and equations,
and all that kind of jazz.
- I'm making roses.
- This is my rose. Going to do her
proud.
- That is not going to stay.
- Just got to finish the ruffles.
I would actually really love to make
something Paul likes today.
- Rough and ready, isn't it?
- But the rose looks amazing.
- Bakers, you have one minute left.
SURA SIGHS
- Ooh, that's scary canary.
- Yeah, really happy. Yeah.
It couldn't have gone better for me,
I don't think.
- They're breaking!
- Going for the less is more.
- Less is not more.
Have you seen mine?
- Whatever, I'm done.
- OK.
- I'm done.
- MATT: - Bakers, your time is up.
Please step away from your bakes.
- Looks awesome, Lottie.
- It looks OK. It looks fine.
- But I'm not happy with OK and fine.
- Nine white chocolate
celebration cakes
now face the judgement
of Paul and Prue.
- I love the way it looks.
- Oh, thank you.
- I think it looks original, it looks
modern. I'd buy that. - Thank you.
Thank you. - It's a
great looking cake.
The naked element of it looks nice.
It's neat.
I love the drips are all
equal as well.
- And so I've got white chocolate cake
with a pistachio
and lemon Genoise and then
a white chocolate sponge with
a marula fruit liquor
and white chocolate
Italian meringue buttercream.
- All the flavours are there,
but they're quite... delicate.
- OK. - It needs more of a hero flavour.
I don't think pistachio's going
to be strong enough.
- It's a beautifully made cake.
The flavour just needs
a bit more oomph.
- A bit more oomph. OK.
- I love that. It's very cool.
I like what you've done
with the sapphire as well.
- I think it's imaginative, I think
it's exciting. - Oh, thank you.
- Beautiful. - Thank you. - Well done,
Lottie.
- It is three white chocolate sponges
with a passion fruit curd
and a lime kind of syrup.
- The flavour's good.
The textures aren't, though.
It's overbaked.
- Mm-hm. - Cos it is bone dry inside.
- Yeah.
- I think, actually, the work
and the chocolate looks fine.
My issue is... - It's leaning.
- ..the shape of the cakes. - Yeah.
- I mean, they're all over the place,
aren't they? - They are.
- Mm.
- You have raw dough.
- It looks like marzipan.
- Your recipe was at fault or you've
weighed something up wrong.
It could have been the
white chocolate with the water.
- Mm. - Yeah, maybe.
- Such a pity it's not edible.
- SHE SIGHS
- It looks wonderful. - Thank you.
- The colour of the sponge worries me
a lot. - OK. - It's very dark.
Let's have a look inside.
- Well, I don't think it's overbaked.
- It does taste really good.
Strawberries work well with it.
- Thank you.
- It's just the colour of
that sponge I don't like.
But overall, I think it's
a decent cake.
- Thank you. - I love it.
- Cool, thank you.
- I really like it. Buttery, white
chocolate, a bit of zest in there.
My issue is the decoration.
The piping work is not good.
At any level. - I think Paul is right.
It's a really delicious cake.
A little dense. Piping not perfect.
- No. - But thank you.
It's really neat. - I think it's
a great looking cake.
- Thank you. - Very pastel. - Yeah.
- Let's have a look, shall we?
- Sponge is a little dense. - OK. - It is.
It's weighed heavy on that. - Yeah.
- But I like the flavour of it and I
love the raspberry
through it as well. - I think you've
done a really good job.
- Thank you. - And it's taste of white
chocolate. - Good. - Yeah, well done.
Thank you. - Thank you very much.
- The colour is beautiful and smooth
and all the way around,
it just looks really neat.
- It's a coconut cake with mango curd
cream in the centre.
Oh, that'll be a chocolate chunk.
- It's like toffee.
It's gluing my teeth together.
- I think it's well baked.
Coconut flavour really comes
through. Mango lightens it up.
You've come up with something that
is very, very neat too. Clever.
- Thanks. - Yeah, well done. Thank you.
It's a little bit messy down at the
bottom. - Yes.
- The top bit's quite cute.
Quite like that.
Just don't seem to go together.
- No, they don't. - It's like two
different cakes, isn't it?
- Mm! Delicious.
- THEY LAUGH
- Delicious.
- So, we call it a Prue-gasm.
"Mm!"
- The lemon works beautifully
with the sponge.
It's got that citrus kick that
you want. - Well done, Hermine.
It's just delicious.
- Thank you. - Thank you very much.
- Sometimes less is more.
That sort of let it down a little
bit. - OK.
- Blackcurrant is beautiful.
I can't really get the white
chocolate, but then,
since there's such a mass of white
chocolate everywhere else,
perhaps that doesn't matter. - Yeah.
- I think your sponges are dried
out slightly
and you probably
slightly overbaked it. - OK.
- But I love the blackcurrant.
- Thank you. - It works beautifully,
actually, with the white chocolate.
You put a lot of thought into it.
- Well, well done, Laura. - Thank you.
I'm a tiny bit disappointed,
I think,
cos I just really wanted to,
like, nail it this week.
- SHE SIGHS
- But the comment
that I really loved was
when Paul said that
a lot of thought had gone into it.
Like, that meant a lot to me.
- Yet! I had a Prue roar!
It's a thing, apparently, now.
She goes, "Mm!"
- SHE LAUGHS
- Went horrific.
I can't believe the cake was, like,
pretty much raw inside.
I honestly don't know to say.
- So, kids, that was a tough week.
But we should talk first
about who could be Star Baker.
- I think Peter. Again, Mr Consistent.
Very clever, very neat.
The colour was very good.
I liked the mango as well.
- Can I talk about Mark L?
Because I think his cake
was just beautiful.
- He's been up there constantly,
Mark L.
- Well, he was third in Technical,
did pretty well in Signature,
and I think he's done
pretty good today.
So I think I would put one of those
two in line for Star Baker.
- Who's in trouble?
- Sura, I think.
- I think based on her
Showstopper being raw.
She made a big mistake with that.
- And probably Lottie.
- She was bottom in the Technical.
Didn't do fantastically
in the Signature.
She did well in the Showstopper,
but has she done enough to stay in
the competition and has Sura really
failed that much that she has to go?
- I really like Lottie and Sura,
so I will go instead of them
if you want.
I'm happy. - Oh, yes. We'll have that.
- See you, mate. - Prue!
I thought I was your favourite!
See how easily they forget once
the new kid's in town?
- The novelty of me will wear off.
I wouldn't get rid of him.
THEY LAUGH
- Hello, Bakers.
I've got the great job
of announcing Star Baker.
So, the Star Baker is...
..Mark L.
- THEY APPLAUD
- Oh, thank you. - Well done, Mark.
- Thank you. - Smashed it. - Well done!
- So, it's up to me
to announce who' is going home,
and it is someone who we are
really fond of,
but who had a bad week.
And so the baker who
will be leaving us this week is...
..Sura.
- I was expecting that.
- You are honestly amazing.
You're so good.
- Never mind. You're a good baker.
- I'm gutted, but what's done is done.
I'm not going to be bitter about it.
I've had a great time.
- Sorry. - That's OK.
- You just had a bad week.
- I hate white chocolate.
I hate chocolate. End of.
I don't think I'll ever eat
chocolate ever again.
- SHE LAUGHS
- I'm really sad to see Sura go.
Now, that's the classic case
of you cannot have a weakness
in your baking if you're going to
win The Great British Bake Off.
And unfortunately
we found Sura's this week,
and it was that that
actually saved Lottie.
- THEY GIGGLE
- Just pick it up for the next one,
yeah? - I will try my best.
- SHE SIGHS
- The sadness that I feel at losing
Sura is at least part way made
up by Mark getting Star Baker.
That... I'll take that.
That'll cheer me up.
Yeah, well done, mate. - Thank you.
I'm quite emotional. - Are you? - Yeah.
- You're hiding it really well. - Am I?
- No.
- HE LAUGHS
- How did that happen?
I can't believe it.
Yeah, I just didn't expect it.
I think consistency
pays off, doesn't it?
Thank you very much. Thank you.
- Yeah, well done. - What a surprise.
- Really good.
- I'm delighted that we're going...
..we're down to the final seven
bakers, you know?
Like... Seven? Eight.
Eight. Is it eight?
Eight bakers.
- HE LAUGHS
Next time... - It's pastry week!
- ..the bakers feel the heat at
the halfway point.
- Halfway to paradise.
- With a strenuous signature...
..a perplexing Technical.
- Hashtag winging it.
- And an astonishing Showstopper...
- It's bonkers.
- ..that will leave one baker
feeling fragile.
- I don't know what to do.
It's just breaking as I'm trying
to get it.
- HE SIGHS
>>>>oakislandtk
www.opensubtitles.org